in good shape your weekly dose of health
information on deutsche welle find out
more about what's new in medical
treatment alternative medicine as well
as nutrition wellness and beauty medical
professionals therapists and counselors
are in our studio to offer their expert
advice on in good shape and my guest in
the studio has not only helped deliver
many many babies he's also an expert in
keeping mother and child healthy before
during and after birth dr lal miah thank
you very much for joining us today thank
you very much for the invitation dr. hey
Maya we've heard about weight gain and
that you should try and keep your weight
in check during pregnancy how much
weight gain is normal when you're
pregnant awaken of 12 kilograms is
normal but it depends on the body mass
index if the body mass index is high
over 30 for example you only have weight
gain recommended that is about eight
kilograms so you know you should take
your initial weight if you're if you're
very slim you could gain a little bit
more right you're not so slim you should
really watch your weight even more well
exactly it's said that if babies are
born with a weight of more than 4,000
grams that's a problem why is that the
case the mother has probably a
gestational diabetes and the baby is
quite big might be very cute but it has
problems with the glucose the mother
gives glucose from the blood or blood
sugar over the placenta to the baby and
the baby is used to produce a lot of
insulin and this insulin will be keep on
when the baby's born and therefore the
level of blood glucose might decrease
and some babies have to stay at the
pediatric department and had to get an
infusion intravenously for example of
glucose so the baby processes the excess
blood sugar of the mum and therefore is
actually born with a malfunctioning
metabolism that's that's right and the
mother is conditioning the baby to have
a diabetes in young years ok well so
keep you away tin shack well one way to
do that is to exercise we've had many
women writing in on that topic wanting
to know what sort of
things they should consider when the
exercise such as August have chick from
Russia she wanted to know what are the
most important do's and don'ts there
that's very important you can make all
sports you have done before normally but
you only have to avoid competitive
sports or ashemar's for example or all
extreme sports yes so sports where you
could actually injure yourself something
like that right to be royalty yes okay
um what about you know women who are not
overweight are they safe from getting
gestational diabetes a lot of slender
people in the industrial countries who
have had gestational diabetes as well if
you have a history for example of
diabetes or a big high blood pressure
you're also at risk for diabetes ok and
the mother is quite old if the mother
gets the first baby over 40 you have
also errors that's when you should ask
your doctor for a special test for
diabetes in pregnancy that's one of the
prenatal tests you can do when you're
expecting there are many many others on
office especially here in Germany which
would you say which prenatal scans are
really useful and necessary Germany they
exist the maternal policy guidelines and
you have a lot of tests but I think very
useful the black group this is
absolutely deeply important because if
you have problems after delivery and you
have to get blood this is very important
and the HIV is necessary because you
can't protect the baby